Gregg Alba's here returning with Andrew
what's up guys he's known as baseball
Andrew my phone Andrew is here we're
gonna watch the sausage party red van
trailer number DOS I heard some rod to
me as if this films getting a really
high person think currently hasn't 100%
and it's been like that for a few weeks
now so I'm excited for this yeah a good
sausage jus just from the initial
trailers it looks hysterical so I can't
wait to see it either hysterical is the
word Andrew thank you for saying that
you're welcome I appreciate that's what
I'm here input friends
and I'm sure three fit-out birds waiting
to get filled with mommy yeah my car is
would ever let Carl get up in them put
your [__] hand down you raining my
joke ketchup your mustard Oh sausages
and buns because we belong together
I know it's against the rules but just
the tips good
that doesn't make any sense why would
they do that because it makes them
stronger
hungers insatiable buddy I mean [__] how
do you know all this
Sweden um perishables [__] I
gotta tell everyone he will die
otherwise thank you mean what because
they're doing this to us because we
touched em just fine it's not like
anyone write home and says oh god I had
the best tip never who can fight these
monsters and take control of our own
lives come on join up fight
make it rain
yo just know could you forget me man
we need to have a fire here goes
everything
hello looking at me with your little
shoes in your arms your legs look at me
I've got no legs you can't attack cm leg
wanted her to do
you don't wanna [__] know
Wow
it's a jam-packed trailer right there
dude there's a lot of different themes
in that trailer like just for one thing
like when that woman is like just going
after you can see the red eyes like the
terminators and I'm like that's now it
was pretty hysterical I think it's a
great spin on the whole like what we get
from like Pixar you know with like Toy
Story and then with the yeah
illumination bringing out the secret
light-up heads now we got sausage
parties
30 car more this is kind of sad though
because I do like food I like hotdogs a
lot the whole idea of tips touching I
went to Catholic school and so yes I can
vouch that God does view that as a sin
he will punish you if you put the tip of
your penis in another Catholics vagina
just warning you don't do it how an
abomination good tip thank you good tip
hey Andrew Andrew with the jokes the
puns yeah this is jam-packed cast is
like everyone you'd see on like a Comedy
Central Roast were so bad like yeah yeah
Seth Rogen you're Kristen Wiig Jonah
Hill bill 8 or Michael Cera James waters
is let's just keeps going on and on out
of all this whole cast so it's like we
know most of them are gonna be really
funny
I want to hear Edward Norton what he
does with the role whatever role he has
because everyone doesn't really do
comedy so I'm excited to see what he
does with a comedic role last time I saw
him do comedy I think it was death to
smoochy and no Birdman's a more dramatic
role but he had some funny I got a
clarity yeah yeah but I mean definitely
wasn't a straight-up comment but I agree
with you Edward Norton is obviously the
most fascinating actor in here so to see
him in a straight-up comedy it's gonna
be interesting to see like his take as
last I mean obviously Birdman like I
said but Hulk is engraved in my mind too
you know it's definitely gonna be
interesting to see what Edward does with
this type of role for sure true
something about it does seem a little
bit repetitive throughout the trailer
like ok I get the joke that these food
that comes to life they swear they talk
like this yeah it's funny but it seemed
like towards the end of the trailer when
they were like actually interacting with
humans which is something different than
what you get from an animated movie I
want to see what they do when they go
all out there as I know it with Seth
Rogen
bored for this they know how to enhance
and go to a new extreme that usually
wouldn't expect I know this is the end
does that they go through like whole new
heights that you're like I didn't see
this coming I know a preacher they
really deliver on that to sausage party
right now it seems very simple very
basic and sure we're gonna get some fun
banter in there between the voice actors
but I really hope that in terms of plot
that it just gets [__] insanely
ridiculous by the finale yeah no
absolutely and I think one of the main
strengths of Seth Rogen and Evan
Goldberg they do a really good job even
when it's a straight-up comedy they do a
good job of balancing the tones of you
know making you laugh a crazy amount
also making you care about the
characters as we saw there are going to
be some dramatic moments where they're
fighting for their life shooting
toothpicks into guys asses I gotta say
that pit at the end killed me with the
toilet papers like you don't want to
know what he did to me looks like
there's gonna be a good balancing tone
like I said between comedy and making
you care about the food and maybe some
of the human characters I really trust
this writing team and like I said we've
got such an amazing cast I expect to be
laughing my ass off in my seat he came
into the toilet paper Andrew oh that
makes sense
before he wiped his ass with where he
wiped his ass then came into this one
oh god he's protectee hysterical I hope
they do that actually you're done that
idea I got almost every day don't tell
people it's part of my thrill it's part
of my thrill ride I'm lonely in these
days well if you're new to my channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects if
you want to subscription services are a
thing that exists in this economy
andrew is part of the channel movie
source check it out him and his cousin
are on there they got great chemistry
they're not gay lovers as one would
assume up front they are related legal
follow us on our social networks links
will be in description box and want to
get shout out to all the Jewish
subscribers out there if you're Jewish
let me know but I'm Andrew is Jewish I
am I have a Jew friend sup Joey hey
how's it going buddy
I'm cool with all races and tyro Magnus
is my black friend thank you